قالت قيلت العمليات الخاصه الامريكيه في
كوريا الجنوبيه الى قوات البحريه الكوريه
الجنوبيه والامريكيه والبريطانيه اجرت
التدريبات مشتركه في البحر الكوري الجنوبي
في منتصف الشهر الجاري وكشفت القياده
الامريكيه في تغريده ان تدريبات شاركت
فيها سفينه البريطانيه اتش ام اس بي
من القوارب القتاليه المتوسطه التابعه
للقوات البحريه الامريكيه الخاصه من طرازق
في سي ان وهي قوارب قادره على تخفي تستخدم
في عمليات تسلل ولم توضح القياده
الامريكيه لما كانت الدقيقه لتدريبات
لكنها اكلت ان التدريب مكانا من اتقان
القدره على اجراء العمليات البحريه
المشتركه عاليه الدقه
مراسل الجزيره محمد البقالي محمد يعني
اللافت في هذه التدريبات هذا التكتم حول
مكانها لماذا
كل شيء كل شيء
حتى اعلن عن هذا التدريب بعد اسبوعين من
اجراءه لم يتم التكتم فقط عن مكانه ولكن
ايضا عن موعده والا وما نشر الان نشرت بعض
الصور الفوتوغرافيه التي لا تحدده لا
المكان ولا الزمان وان كان على كل حال
والد على انه تم اجراه في منتصف هذا الشهر
ولكن هذا الامر بشكل عام ليس سرا هناك
الان تدريب مشتركه معلنه بين كوريا
الجنوبيه وبين الولايات المتحده كانت تدري
في الشهر المقبل ايضا تم الاعلان على انها
ستتحاكي سيناري حدوث هجوم نووي من قبل
كوريا الشماليه
وهناك ايضا تفاعل كبير في المنطقه الان
التي تشهده نوعا من التوتر منذ بدايه
السنه مع اطلاق كوريا الشماليه لصواريخ
باليسيه وارسالها لطائرات مسيره اخترقت
الاجواء كوريا الجنوبيه بالاضافه الى
اعلان كوريا الشماليه على انها ترغب في
امتلاك اكبر طرسانه النوويه في العالم كل
هذا القاب ظلاله ثقله على المنطقه برمتها
خاصه وانه هناك حربا اخرى تجري داخل
اوروبا حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وهذه لا
يتم فصلها عن تلك بالنظر الى ان الاطراف
المتسارعه هنا لديها علاقات مع ما يحدث
هناك طبعا كوريا الشماليه تعطى ينظر اليها
لانها مقربه من روسيا والصين ايضا ينظر
اليها على ان حليفه روسيا وبالتالي هناك
تشكل لما يمكن ان نسميه بمعسكرين اجواء
الحرب البارده في الحقيقه تعود الى هذه
المنطقه المعسكر الغربي تقوده الولايات
المتحده ومعه كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
هناك 28,000 جندي امريكي في قاعده عسكريه
هنا ومعسكر الذي يضم كلا من روسيا والصين
وكوريا الشماليه وغيره ودون اخرى في هذا
السياق يمكن عبد الصمد يعني هذا اليوم وصل
الامير العام بحلف الشماليه الاطلسيه همم
وتصريحاته كانت في هذا الاتجاه قال بانه
ما يحدث في هذه المنطقه له تا مباشر على
دولي الحلف في الغرب وما يحدث في الغرب له
تاثير مباشر على هذه المنطقه وذكر بالاسم
كلا من كوريا الجنوبيه التي قال انها تشكل
تهديدا عالميا خطرا وذكر الصين ايضا قال
ان الصين ترغب الان بسرعه في الحصول في
تطوير اسلحه طويله المدى يمكن ان تصل الى
الدول حلف النيته وهنا يمكن ان نفهم ما
حده الموضوع وقوته واهميته بالنسبه للغرب
مما يدفع الامين العام لحزبره القيام
بجوله تشمل كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان سيصل
الوزير الدفاع الامريكي وكل هذا يعطينا
فكره على ما يمر في هذه المنطقه لك محمد
البقالي مراسل الجزيره من سوريا